en el vídeo anterior introdujimos la
idea de que era una ecuación diferencial
lineal de segundo orden y de hecho
estuvimos trabajando con las ecuaciones
lineales segundo orden pero del tipo
homogéneas también probamos sus
propiedades muy importantes la primera
era que una constante multiplicada por
una solución también la solución y que
da suma de dos soluciones también era
una solución en esta ocasión quiero ver
en caso particular y encontrar su
solución general mi ecuación particular
va a ser esta vez que mi prima más 5 y
prima más 6
y esto lo voy a igualar a 0 dese cuenta
que lo que estoy buscando es una función
que cumpla esta ecuación es decir una
función que al derivar las dos veces y
sumar la con cinco veces su primera
derivada y sumar la con seis veces ella
misma nos tienen que dar cero y dese
cuenta que esta es una ecuación
diferencial de segundo orden con
coeficientes constantes y además que es
homogénea
pero pese a ello no es tan fácil
encontrar una solución por ejemplo si
ponemos no se ve igual a x cuadrada si
ponemos ya iguala en es cuadrada pues su
primera derivada es 2x y su segunda
derivada sería 2 y si las sumamos en
realidad no nos da cero si se dan cuenta
no es tan fácil de encontrar una
solución a este problema
sin embargo adivinen qué función va a
llegar a la fiesta de este vídeo qué
función es esencialmente muy parecida a
su primera derivada y a su segunda
derivada y ya cualquiera de sus
derivadas si se acuerdan bien días en un
poco de memoria y además han visto los
vídeos que he realizado se van a dar
cuenta que esa función
una de las funciones más hermosas en
matemáticas la función de la equis pero
quiero que vean que no forzosamente está
al cual le a la equis si sustituimos a
la x en esta ecuación pues claramente no
me da 0 la segunda derivada de la x sea
la x más 5 veces su primera derivada que
sea la x más 6 veces l x es 10 pero qué
tal si ponemos en lugar de ea la x que
iguala a a la x donde r va a ser una
constante y yo sé que ustedes se van a
preguntar por qué escogió e iguala a la
x pero lo que voy a hacer es sustituir
en esta ecuación y buscar una r y cumpla
esta ecuación diferencial del segundo
orden
es decir voy a ajustar esa r para que
realmente me cumpla esto primero voy a
sacar la primera derivada de igual a
ella la rx
que por la regla de la cadena es ere por
el ere x esto lo hago para poder
sustituir bien ahora saquemos la segunda
derivada de mi prima va a ser la
derivada de rx pero como r es una
constante entonces va a bajar me va a
quedar encuadrada y al aire x bien y
esto para qué pues voy a sustituir con
un nuevo color y vamos a ver qué es lo
que me queda sustituyendo mi prima puede
ser re cuadrada y a la rx más cinco
veces y en prima pero ya prima es lo que
está aquí entonces me queda 5 r
x más seis veces la función original es
decir seis veces
a la rx y esto tiene que ser igual a
cero y lo primero que veo es que la mx
aparece en cada uno de mis mantos
entonces yo lo puedo sacar como factor
común
además recuerden que tenemos que
resolver esta ecuación para una era
especial
bien pues entonces saquemos el aire es
como factor común que me va a
multiplicar a r cuadrada más 5 r más 6 y
pues todo esto tiene que ser igual a 0
hasta aquí hemos llegado a que toda esta
expresión es decir a la rx que
multiplica a r cuadrada más 5 r 6 tiene
que ser igual a 0 todo esto de aquí pero
aquí hay una de las propiedades más
bonitas de la exponencial cuando la
exponencial se hace 0 pues la respuesta
es nunca ya la rx nunca se hace 0 por lo
tanto no va a quedar de otra más que
erre cuadrada más 56 pues tenga que ser
igual a 0 a esto me refería cuando les
decía que teníamos que ajustar la r y lo
voy a escribir aquí abajo es re cuadrada
más 5 r más 6 esto es igual a 0 a esta
ecuación r cuadrada más 56 se le conoce
como la ecuación característica asociada
a mí
a diferencia del segundo orden y es que
resolver el problema que teníamos
originalmente de cuestiones
diferenciales se redujo a sacar las
raíces de una ecuación de segundo grado
y de hecho esta ecuación de segundo
grado se puede actualizar en r2 pues que
multiplica a r3 y esto tiene que ser
igual a cero aquí ya podemos encontrar
la raíz es muy sencillo porque pues esta
parte tiene que ser cero r más 2 y
entonces me sale que mi primera raíz es
r igual a menos 2 y por otra parte r 3
es igual a 0
pues si es rival de menos 3 y acabo de
encontrar ya por fin mis dos raíces
tales que si la sustituyó en mi función
original ya tengo la solución de mi
ecuación diferencial de segundo grado es
decir que sí que vale a la menos 2 x 10
1 le voy a poner y por otra parte
utilizando mi otra raíz de mi polinomio
característico me queda que al menos 3
usando la otra raíz a la menos 3 x
también es solución y ustedes se van a
preguntar pues esta es la solución más
general del problema es decir que con
esto acabamos y pues la respuesta es que
no en el vídeo pasado si se acuerdan
habíamos visto que es multiplica vamos a
nuestra solución por una constante
también es la solución entonces pues
vamos a multiplicar y 1 por una
constante sea un ok entonces yo sé que
lleva 1 por una constante seguro que no
forzosamente es un 9 puede ser cualquier
constante es también solución entonces
esto de dar la familia de soluciones que
tienen que ver con que uno y de manera
análoga para allá dos si lo multiplicó
por una constante pues una constante 2a
pues también es solución esto me da una
forma más general y de hecho me va a dar
pie a la solución general de esta
ecuación diferencial otra de las cosas
que habíamos probado en el vídeo pasado
es que la suma de dos soluciones también
en la solución y eso lo voy a ocupar
para escribir
x
es decir una función que esta vez
solamente va a depender de x como la
solución general iba a ser c 1 por el
ala menos 2 x + c 2 por el ala menos 3x
y es la solución general de la ecuación
diferencial que yo quería resolver
seguramente tú me vas a decir oye sal es
que pues yo no te creo que sea la
solución general a ver pruébalo pero la
demostración es un poco complicada y
algo engorrosa entonces por ahora lo
tomaremos como dogma de fe y es más lo
voy a subrayar de verde para que se vea
más como dogma de fe bien otra cosa que
yo creo que te debes estar preguntando
vídeo en de emergya de esas dudas de tu
cabeza es oye en las ecuaciones
diferenciales de primer orden pues yo
tenía una constante y tenía una
condición inicial y con esto lo resolví
amos pero es una instalación yo tengo
dos constantes será necesario que yo
necesite dos condiciones iniciales y la
respuesta es sí
más bien en tu intuición voy a necesitar
dos condiciones iniciales para poder
determinar mis constantes de hecho una
de estas puede ser igual a una condición
inicial y la primera derivada de james
ward a otra condición inicial pero de
esto me voy a encargar en el siguiente
vídeo así que nos vemos pronto